ey ich ich warum bin ich nicht
vorbereitet ich bin nicht vorbereitet
was ist das das ist das
Fragenlotto da sind unverschämte Fragen
drin und harmlose Fragen an mich
ja grün sind die harmlosen rot sind die
unverschämten da gucke ich mal nicht hin
ich lasse mich überraschen ah was war
das ist
unversch ich mach mal auf stelle ich dir
jetzt die Frage oder muss ich die mir
selber stell du kannst die Frage dir
selber stellen ich werde sie nicht
beantworten können so schlimm was steht
bei mir steht nichts drin
doch ist Werbung Käse
m
eiglich musst ja ganz klar mit ja
beantworten aber eiglich ja ja leerder
mal Käse ist
Werbung ja finde ich schon ehrlich
gesagt mich nervt ist Manipulation hoch
10 leider erreicht es mich trotzdem kann
ich nichts gegen machen ich ich gucke es
versuche viel wegzppen allerdings ist es
für mich als Switch Reloaded Mitglied
natürlich dankbar weil ich daraus
natürlich auch viel nehmen kann und wir
parodieren ja auch auf Werbespots unter
anderem jetzt in der dritten
Staffel diese
fr denn kennt ihr nicht fr alle nicken
außer dir was das ist doch sicher ein
Smoothie ja na genau so so ein egal
kommt noch kommt noch auf jeden Fall da
bin ich natürlich froh dass es diese
schlimmen Werbespots gibt weil wir da
weil wir und das dürft ja in dem auf dem
Fernsehsender die Werbung die da
vielleicht läuft klar sens ja klar aber
du hast s ja auch hast ja selber Werbung
gemacht und wie du erzählt hast wirst du
da oft wieder war so schrecklich ich bin
bis bis letzten Monat Vegetarier gewesen
10 Jahre und meine Schwester hat
gegrillt und zur Feier des Tages schön
frisches Fleisch und ich bekam wieder
die gefüllte Paprika und ich weiß nicht
was an dem Tag los war auf jeden Fall
musste ich in dieses Fleisch beißen und
seit dem Tag esse ich täglich von
morgens bis abends zum Frühstück zum
Mittag und zum
Abendbrot Wurst und Fleisch lecker ne ja
ja was Gewissen aber ich denke ich werde
es wieder einstellen ich gucke jetzt mal
ein halbes Jahr wie der Körper so
reagiert und wie es mir geht und
beobachte das jetzt mal aber
ich denke dass ich so zu Weihnachten
dann nach
Weihnachten wieder Vegetarier sein werde
ja deswegen wir haben wir noch Fragen ja
also du kannst so aufziehen wie du
möchtest jetzt nehm ich mal die harmlose
die war ja wirklich feuchtbar ja ja die
ist auch furchtbar also die sind
furchtbar habmlos du weißt doch gar
nicht was ich gezogen habe muss ich die
alle beantworten ne nee
okay was sind ihre
Vorzüge
habe ich denn Vorzüge habe ich welche
sag die sind auch schwierig die Fragen
mit Sicherheit
irgendwas ja da ist sie wieder eine
dieser Fragen blockiert blockiert habe
ich V ich bin unheimlich also ein ein
Nachteil bei dir wäre blockiert nee dass
ich sehr schüchtern bin was ein Nachteil
ist dass ich sehr sehr schüchtern bin
was niemand von mir erwartet
witzigerweise ich bekam gestern Abend
ganz ganz viele Anrufe nach dem
Interview alle meinten Mann warst du
schüchtern dachte ich so echt ja ich
dachte ich wä wirkte sverän und
authentisch aber die waren irgendwie
hatten irgendwie das Gefühl ich
bin schüchterner als ich sonst im
privaten Leben rüberkomme schüchtern
auch ein Vorteil ein Vorzug ja genau
mein Vorzug ich bin sehr
schüchtern noch eine ja du kannst jetzt
sagen jetzt reicht re wir wollten doch
stöen wir wollten noch mehr stöen
okay sind sie glücklich
ähm ja
ja kann ich von mir behaupten zurzeit
bin ich ich bin gesund ich lebe in der
Stadt in der ich seit zwei Jahren leben
wollte und seit letzter Woche endlich
lebe ich
[Musik]
ähm
Liebe und habe eine gesunde Familie und
mein Bruder jetzt um die Ecke wohnen
worüber ich sehr sehr glücklich bin und
das Interview ist gleich vorbei worüber
ich besonders glücklich bin dass ich das
jetzt hinter mir habe und hoffentlich
nicht zu viel kauderw von mir gelassen
hab keinen Fall und deswegen bin ich
jetzt in diesem Moment sehr sehr sehr
glücklich soll darauf beruhen lassen
bitte pass auf ich ziehe gib mir mal
noch ich ziehe und dann entscheide ich
draf hab oder
nicht oh
Gott so ich bedanke mich für das
Interview Gernes und ja hoffe auf ein
Wiedersehen ja ich auch auf Wiedersehen
da hätte ich jetzt ein kauderwtpan mir
gegeben das wä jetzt das wä jetzt ja
also vor allem hätte ich mich da
bestimmt verquatscht und nein wunderbar
hat großen Spaß gemacht ja mir super
bedingt aber doch doch war okay